welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 27
and we're gonna learn how billionaires
continue to work hard
on their dreams enjoy
[Music]
you need to work if depending on how
well you want to do and particularly if
you're starting a company you need to
work super hard
so what what does super hard mean well
when my brother and i were starting our
first company
instead of getting an apartment we just
rented us a small office and we slept on
the couch
and we showered at the ymca and
uh we're so hot up we had just one
computer so
the the website was up during the day
and i was coding at night seven days a
week all the time
and i i briefly had a girlfriend in that
period and in order to
be with me she had to sleep in the
office so
i work hard like
it i mean every waking hour that's
that's the the thing i would i would say
if you particularly if you're starting a
company um
and i mean if you do simple math say
like okay if somebody else is working
50 hours and you're working 100 you'll
get twice as done
as much done in the course of a year as
the other company
what would be one word of advice you
would have for an upcoming businessman
knowledge knowledge but if it's one word
one word is very hard for that but
the word is knowledge but you get
knowledge
through experience one of the things
people talk about is luck and i do
believe that people are lucky and some
people are luckier than others i do
believe that
but there's also an expression the
harder you work the luckier you get
and i can tell you ten instances where i
didn't quit
one it was 1990 the world was coming
down the debt markets were
everybody all of my friends and enemies
were going bankrupt i never did
and the but try i mean the times were
actually just terrible
and even today you look at times and you
see what happens and you have to learn
but the word luck is very interesting
but if i didn't work
really hard i probably would not almost
definitely would not be here today and
unless you had me up as a man who at one
point was successful
but let's see what a loser looks like so
you have to work hard because it is true
you can develop
luck through hard work most people do a
lot of talking and most people don't put
in the effort
there's nothing you can't accomplish in
life
with the right amount of work the
challenge is you know are you willing to
to do the work and
the reality is most people aren't but
that's the opportunity
right it's i mean it's like people you
know at school
most people are lazy right they just
they barely get through it and
and so that creates opportunity some
people just
they get on the show and they think you
know i don't have to work anymore
i don't have to work as hard or if i get
an investor it'll be easier
and it never works that way or um
they just they stop paying attention to
detail
yeah right i've had a couple companies
where it's like
all right you know i'll hire people to
do all the work
it's your company it's your baby you've
got to do you
you know if you're not going to do the
work who is and i've always felt you
know in terms of leadership
that my job is to put everybody around
me in a position to succeed
and if i'm walking around the arena here
i'm picking up
junk on the ground i'm you know helping
customers i'm trying to
you know convey to everybody that
there's not a job that you would do that
i wouldn't do myself
and a lot of entrepreneurs that fail
they lose they lose track of that
they think you know i'm the boss i mean
i had
i had a job one time and i was a
horrible employee where
you know the the president of the
company spent more time telling me how i
should dress
than trying to help me close sales yeah
you know so you've got to do the work
and that's key i tell my kids that a if
they want something
they're going to have to earn it yeah
and b if they don't work hard enough to
earn it i'm going to sell them off as
medical experiments
that's the line in our house right
i'm going to sell you off this medical
experience
[Laughter]
you need money okay we'll sell you off
as a medical experiment we can get you
money that way
i'll go give blood dad i'm seven i don't
care
working at your business software it
actually went really good for a while
because
um i i didn't have a tech background
and so it gave me the opportunity to
teach myself
and i found out that i like tech you
know which was shocking to me
and so i would sit in there and use the
computers and teach myself all the
software
from way back when the word stars the
word perfects the
you know the peachtree softwares for
those of us that go way back when
and um one day and mind you i'm sleep
i'm living in a three bedroom apartment
with six guys
six 23 24 year old guys
however nasty you think it is it was
worse
i didn't have a closet i didn't have a
drawer
i had a pile and i i wore contacts
i wore contacts so but i wear my glasses
at night
and i didn't have any money so i broke
my glasses and i would
hit them up and they'd tear them apart
and hide one piece here one piece there
oh it was an adventure but um
but so one day i'm living in this hill
and um i get the opportunity
to close a big deal and it was going to
be 1500
commission to me i'm like yes sir let's
go
and um i called my boss guy named
michael humecki
um and i said michael i've got this deal
and part of my job responsibilities
were sweeping the floor it was a retail
store sweeping the floor
making sure the windows were clean and
opening up and i've got
you know one of my um fellow employees
all set to do all that
i called him up and said michael it's a
15 000
sale but i need to go pick it up
before before work i won't be there to
open things up he goes no
i need you to open up the store i'm like
i got it covered and i make the
executive decision that i'm going to go
pick up the check
and i'm going to hand him the check and
he's going to forget all about it we're
all going to be friends and i'll make my
commission
fired me for disobeying him
um i haven't seen him since
but that's probably the best thing that
could have happened yeah right
but in any event um but it made me
realize that i
i need to work for myself again you know
that i'm an entrepreneur at heart
and so i just you know it's not this is
what it is
and um and so i couldn't take the 1500
commission it was his company it was his
sale and and so
i found another customer that i've been
talking to a prospect
a company called architectural lighting
and here i am sleeping in the show with
no job and desperate um
but i convinced this this company
architectural lighting there was a piece
of software
that i wanted to sell them for 500 bucks
and i told them it cost me 250
and that i would make it work and train
them on it and support them
if they would loan me the 250 to buy the
software up front
and if it didn't work for whatever
reason i'd walk their dogs clean their
cars
you know scrub their toilets whatever it
took to pay them back
and fortunately it worked and that led
to another customer which led to another
customer
that was a company called micro
solutions
over the next seven years i didn't take
a vacation taught myself how to program
taught myself
you know more about technology of
networking than i thought
i would ever know and we grew to you
know
give or take 36 million in sales 80
employees
and i sold it back you know 1990 i guess
um
time flies for six million dollars but
for you know a 29 30 year old kid
that was real money and and so um
then it's big money and not that it's
not now it really is but
it's just but it to get from the time of
getting fired
to getting to 80 employees and 36
million in sales
literally not one vacation my television
career began
unexpectedly uh as you heard this
morning i was in the miss fire
prevention contest
that was when i was 16 years old in
nashville tennessee
and you had the requirement of having to
have red hair
in order to win up until the year that i
entered
so they were doing the question and
answer period because i knew i wasn't
going to win in the swimsuit competition
so during the question and answer period
the question
came why young lady what would you like
to be when you grow up
and by the time they got to me all the
good answers were gone
so i had seen barbara walters on the
today show that morning so i answered
i would like to be a journalist i would
like to
tell other people's stories in a way
that makes a difference
in their lives and the world and as
those words were coming out of my mouth
i went whoa
this is pretty good
i would like to be a journalist i want
to make a difference
well i was on television by the time i
was 19 years old
and in 1986 i launched my own television
show
with a relentless determination to
succeed at first
i was nervous about the competition and
then
i became my own competition raising the
bar
every year pushing pushing pushing
myself as hard as i knew
sound familiar to anybody here
eventually
we did make it to the top and we stayed
there for 25
years
the oprah winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21 years and i have to
tell you i became
pretty comfortable with that level of
success
i have paid attention to my life because
i
understand that my life just like your
life
is always speaking to you where you
are in the language with the people
with the circumstances and experiences
that
you can understand and interpret if you
are willing to see that
always life god
is speaking to you now
it took me a while to actually really
get this and to understand it but once i
did
i started paying attention to everything
and one of the reasons why i can now
accept the fact
that i can offer my
gatherings of information and wisdom and
call myself a spiritual teacher
is that every single person whoever came
on my show and i hear there's like
37 000 guests i've talked to
a lot of them came from dysfunction and
a lot of them wouldn't appear to be
teachers but every one of them had
something to say that was meaningful and
valuable
and that i could use to grow myself
into the best of myself which is what
all of our jobs are your number one job
is to become more of yourself and to
grow yourself
into the best of yourself life is short
life should be fun
and it should be fun not you know it
should be if if the
the chairman of the company's having fun
you know if you go to a party and
you know if i let my hair down and i'm
the first to be thrown in the swimming
pool and
uh and i'm not just sitting standing in
the corner of the room sipping
sherry or something uh then everybody
will have a laugh and everybody have it
fun
you know if your gemini company be the
first to dance on the table you know
just
get everybody else up dancing on the
table and make sure the parties
you know the parties are laughed so uh
you know so
play hard and uh play hard work hard and
then
uh and you know follow certain
principles in life you know be
you know you know love people make make
sure you make a positive difference in
this world
while you're on it how early in life did
you your relentless ambition begin did
this happen when you were very young
you alluded to the fact that you sold
papers at age six or something
well i don't know it's just uh i don't
really feel like i'm that ambitious
oh come on i'd hate to follow you around
for a week yeah well i just
work hard but i know a lot of people
that work hard my father worked hard and
set an example for me and
uh and i know a lot of people that work
hard what does that mean working hard
what is your daily part is you know
hustle all day long you know you talk
about hustlers pete rose on the baseball
field i try and do that all day long and
that's what i think we need to do here
in america i mean
the people working in the american
automobile industry we gotta out hustle
the japanese we've gotta
get that old roll up our sleeves and get
back to work and then we'll get this
country out of trouble we can do
anything better than anybody else in the
world that's your life
but if we gotta re-awake that uh
that spirit that's what i try and do
with the atlanta braves is get everybody
hustling because it's it's it sets a
good example for the people that are
watching the program you should work to
earn
to be helped
right so
in order to encourage my 8 17 founders
and all the people who joined us i said
our competitors are very
strong at that time our competitor was
ebay
a lot of the ebay guys from
graduate from harvard we are people
graduate from no no
i don't even mention about the
university names
well nobody but i say if we can
win if we can succeed
80 percent of the young people in china
in the world can be successful
because we believe we work a lot of our
dreams
but they don't work hard a lot of work
hard but they don't have dreams
entrepreneurs should work plus dreams
in this way we can win who works harder
the people at ebay are the people at
alibaba
sometimes you have not only have to work
how you have to work smart
so would you say you work smarter than
ebay i'd have to say yes right
well so far yeah so so far okay because
because i think you know um
we are pretty lucky people and uh
the people say you yeah you work very
hard true in this world there's so many
people work very hard
but they're not that i i told my team
when we i'd peeled
i asked a lot of people sitting there i
said you know all of you guys more of a
guy millionaires
and so rich but 15 years ago
who are we it's so difficult for us to
hide people 15 years ago
people who are not that bad i said
people can walk still walk on the street
we hide them
because nobody believe internet nobody
believe internet and they join the
company
those people who believe they are smart
they were headhunted by to the other
company they set up their own company
those people no nobody go to huntingdon
they stayed today they'd be
successful very key reasons
we insist will persist we never give up
we believe the dreams together
we had been working day and night these
were pretty maniacal days
in terms of work was everything even
you know i didn't believe in weekends or
vacations
the team pretty broadly had worked super
super hard
the marketing people had figured out how
to take this phenomena
and you know get create a lot of
excitement around it
i worked most of my life in high school
there was stewart's cleaners
after school would go there i would put
the drape on the hanger
the sleeve on the hanger and the janitor
of all the cleaners clean everything up
i worked for a dollar and a quarter an
hour
the only reason was a dollar and a
quarter an hour is because if steward
had to pay that
it was required by law or he'd be giving
me 50 cents an hour he was a very tight
very tightwad guy
so i come in one day after school and he
says to me to go to work he says johnny
come here i want to talk to you it's
okay
dr sturdy says johnny i was upstairs
yesterday
and i napped after i finished working i
was tired and i dropped my watch on the
floor i put on the tablet on the floor
and i went down i picked it up and i
noticed
under the cot i was laying on there was
no dust i moved the cot
there was no dust i looked behind the
filing cabinets there was no dust there
whatsoever
zero dust you really are a great janitor
i said it's my job to do what i do
when i do it not when someone else is
looking
tightest guy in the world gave me a 25
cent race to a dollar fifty
where i went to high school i was the
highest paid kid and maybe adult in the
neighborhood
we didn't have a lot of money in those
days what it was was
if people if humans can imagine
doing what you have to do when nobody
is watching you you're doing is if
someone is right there watching you
and in your free time you're not trying
to elongate something
you're doing what you should do without
people
watching you do it pick areas you think
are interesting that could be valuable
where there's a lot of activity
i was interested in links because i knew
no one else was really looking at the
links on the web
and i figured you know you could
probably do something with them and
i think that's true of many of these
areas where people people do interesting
things
i also think it's really important for
us when we were
when we were working on this we had many
people sergey and i and a couple of
other people
who are tremendously worked tremendously
hard
and i think that was an important part
of
of making all this work many of you will
tell me that
will tell you that you're crazy you have
to be a little crazy to
invest the amount of time and energy
that it takes to start a new business
you have to put in long hours and give
weekends up
no more time with the family uh you have
to take financial risks
but building something from the ground
up really is
uh one of the most rewarding things that
you can ever do
and every day it's an opportunity to
experiment and every day it's an
opportunity to try
new things i'm not smarter than anybody
else but i can outwork you
and my key to success for
you or for anybody else is make sure
you're the first one in there every day
and the last one to leave
don't ever take a lunch break or go to
the bathroom you keep working
you never know when that opportunity is
going to come along and at solomon
brothers
uh the managing partner of the company
bill solomon was the
second person in i was the only other
one in the big trading room
so if he had needed to borrow a match in
those days people smoke cigars and
if he wanted to ask something about a
newspaper or a stock
he came over and so we became buddies i
would never have
gotten to talk to the managing partner
of a big company
on a first name basis if it wasn't for
the fact that the two of us are there
billy i'm getting coffee would you like
some
uh and i can bring you that and at the
end of the day the number two guy john
good friend he was the last one to leave
except for me and we'd share a cab going
uptown or take the subway train going
uptown together
and you know every opportunity ever had
it was
i think a lot a lot of them was because
i was there at the time
and that's the one thing you can control
you can you can't control your luck but
the harder you work the luckier you get
you can't control that you're the
smartest guy they'll always be somebody
smarter
but if you're there then you absorb
things you put things together in a ways
that if you didn't have all that
experience
it's like skiing i've said reading a
book on skiing
doesn't teach you how to ski you got to
go and you got to
ski and get lots of miles under your
skis
and incidentally if you don't fall
you're not skiing hard enough and you're
not learning anything so
if your career has ups and downs i got
fired didn't turn out so bad
but you know you can start a little
business and maybe it doesn't work and
after a while you gotta say be smart to
say hey i tried it
don't let your ego get in the way i
can't keep doing this i've got to earn a
living
but you know a year from now i'm going
to come up with a better idea and then
i'll go back and do it again
it's funny sometimes i talk to my wife
about this but like hard work is like
super important in life
and like now like i grew up like in
berkeley i didn't have any money i
played for the
football for the yellow jackets i was
just like a kid in the neighborhood
and now like i have a lot of money and
so like with my kids i'm like okay now
that i'm rich
how do i teach you the value of hard
work because that's really the only
important lesson that i've got
but like for all of you i think uh most
of you
at a public university probably know a
little of the value of hard work keep
that lesson that's the input
that work is what's important um it's
that effort
where you learn the secrets that are
super valuable
and can change people's lives and change
the world
there's a latin expression which i think
is great i love it it was in a
now very old movie called the dead poet
society
but the line of the movie was carpe diem
seize the day
the opportunities are there but you got
to reach out and pick them up
you've got to grab at them some of you
may have already done that at the u in
your classes
in other students that you met in your
extracurricular activities but grab them
don't be afraid to make a mistake
because you know what you can do if you
grab the wrong one
drop it and pick up another one it's
okay
seize the day i think back of
all of the the the luck but also the
times that were in front of me
to seize the day i don't know what got
me to drop out of business school
and come to microsoft my parents thought
i was a whack job
neither one of them graduated college
and they thought this was really a wild
idea
i was lucky i seized the day
microsoft one day some guys fly in
from from ibm and all of a sudden we
figure out we could actually
provide all the software they need for
this thing that became
the personal computer people
bill paul they had the wisdom to seize
the day when that
opportunity presented itself and yet
when you think of all the opportunities
when i think back of all the
opportunities i've had
the one that was most important was an
opportunity i got
1969 sitting in my
junior high school class i was in a
public junior high
not very stimulated at the time and over
the loudspeaker
they said that a private high school in
our area that i'd never heard of
was giving scholarship tests that
weekend
i told my mother i wanted to take him
she said that's fine as long as you get
a scholarship because we can't afford to
send you there
but that's really where i got switched
on switched on in math switched on
personally energized in a way that
never never could be turned back and i'm
very
thankful for that opportunity yes
there's a lot of luck
in opportunity but there's a lot of
seizing the day
and i encourage you all to reach out and
carpe diem really seize the
opportunities that are in front of you
a young person starting their career
i think there are probably a lot of
things some of them are very well known
and people have heard them many times
they're still true
one of those that you should always
focus on a young person should
find something that they're passionate
about to do
and that's not going to surprise anyone
it's it's a clear thing to do it's very
hard if you don't love your work
you're never going to be great at it um
i think the other thing i would suggest
to any young person even before they
start their career
is to really think about their choices
because i find young people and i
i when i was young i had i made this
mistake too
you can get very fixed on your
gifts so everybody has gifts you know
you you have gifts and you have things
that you didn't get gifted maybe you're
extremely beautiful maybe you're
extremely good at mathematics maybe you
there are a lot of things that you can
be given but those things can confuse
you
because they're not the things that
construct your life it's your
choices that construct your life not
your gifts you can celebrate your gifts
be proud of them be happy of them
actually don't be proud of them be
celebratory of them but you can't be
proud because they're gifts they were
given to you you didn't earn them
you can only be proud of the things you
earn and so
as i got older i started to realize i
wasn't proud of my gifts i was always
good at school
school was always easy for me and i was
always proud that i was a great student
i got a's in all my classes i was good
at math
all of that and i thought i thought
that's who i was
but it's not true those are the things
that are gifts
what was hard for me is deciding to work
hard
deciding to use my gifts in certain ways
to challenge myself to do things that i
didn't think i could do to put myself in
uncomfortable situations
we all get i would say to a young person
you can choose a life
of ease and comfort or you can choose a
life
of service and adventure which one of
those when you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of we all
have adversity in our lives
you i i would i would i doubt if you
really
you know if you know somebody any friend
or anybody that you talk to
um there's no lack of adversity and
the uh and by the way that's good
because it's what teaches us how to get
back up you fall down you get back up it
always happens
and uh you know you get certain um
gifts in life and you want to take
advantage of those
but you i guess my advice on adversity
and success would be
to be proud not of your gifts
but of your hard work and your choices
so you know you may be the kinds of
gifts you get you know you might be
really good at math it might be really
easy for you that's a kind of gift
but practicing that math and taking it
to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat that's a choice
you can't really be proud of your gifts
because they were given to you you can
be grateful for them
and thankful for them and but your
choices
you choose to work hard you choose to do
hard
things those are choices that you can be
proud of
i remember my dad my dad died when i was
10 years old he didn't have a problem
with work he said work is good
he said more work is better he said lots
of work is even better than that
and if you could get a whole bunch of
people working together you could
actually accomplish something
now fast forward you know to to
somewhere in the last
20 years work became an addiction
like oh my god you're a work addict
you're a compulsive work person
you're overachiever you have problems in
your life i'm like dude
the only problem i got in my life is
that you telling me work is a
bad thing the more i work the better i
am the more i get accomplished the
happier i am
the more i work in the more accomplished
the better i feel about myself
i'm not trying to fill up a hole i'm
trying to get my reach my potential
lebron shows up this dude comes in
15 minutes before practice and lebron
gives him that look like
hey dude what what's going on here he's
like what do you mean i'm 15 minutes
early he's like should have been here an
hour ago
and and and when he says that to this
dude
the guy knows lebron's been there for
two hours
so all i ask you to do like here's a guy
probably the best that's ever walked out
on a basketball court
short of michael jordan but both of them
had one thing in common
they worked okay it wasn't about their
just their talent it was about their
work ethic people knew them for their
work ethic so
just ask yourself this week do people
know you for your work ethic
or people are people like man you work
hard
are people actually commenting about you
showing up early and staying late
because if they're not then you're just
you're just blending in with everybody
else's work ethic
at the end of the day talent will not
win the game it is work ethic that will
win the game
so when i saw this i'm like here's a guy
top of his games got all the money you
could possibly
he could never spend all his money
impossible he'll be a billionaire
okay and he's showing up two hours early
to make sure he plays the game to make
sure he's in physical condition
to make sure that he can stay in the
game long past
he doesn't even need it he's got all his
rings i got to tell you i
i was so inspired by because i got a
bunch of partners i got guys that i do
business with i got one of them in
particular that i'm having some problems
with
he told me man if i had your money dude
i would retire
he said it to me over and over and i
hadn't been listening to it enough
to to understand he wants to go lay down
okay you cannot run what's that thing
called you did
you can't do an iron man with that
attitude no don't know why you'd want to
do an iron man
but i tell you what if you could do an
iron man and then take that and add it
to your
to your to your career to the
the longevity of your career you know
because
look it's going to be five years from
now 10 years from now it's going to be
20 years you're going to look back and
say
and the marketplace is going to reward
whatever you do every day hey what does
ryan seacrest tom cruise oprah
steven spielberg donald trump joan
rivers
warren buffett gordon ramsay michael
jordan kobe
tim tebow what do those guys have in
common
one thing okay and it's not because
they're in hollywood or doing something
hollywood
they all have one major thing in common
dude unbelievable and probably at the
top of the list is
ryan seacrest when i say ryan seacrest
what do you think
american idol radio no no ryan
seacrest look it up in the dictionary
it equals work ethic okay these people
hammer they beat it to death okay look
at tom cruise man look at his career
he works constantly so look you want to
get your work ethic
so high that people actually admire you
i'm going to ask you a question
right now do people know you because of
your unbelievable work ethic
if you can't answer yes to that man
you're not going to get in that top 10
percent
you got to get at the top you people
have to know you
not because oh he's a good salesman oh
he's a good this oh he's an
artist so he's a good pianist oh he's a
he he writes a great
you know story no did people need to
know you for one major thing first
he works he produces the guy's there
every day the guy's pushing and shoving
because the truth is no matter how good
your ideas are how good your art is or
how good your skill set is
if you're not working man if you're not
vibrating at a frequency that people say
my god how does that guy do all that
if you're not vibrating at that rate 10x
levels
massive action tremendous work ethic
that's just a muscle now and it's
it's just a discipline in your life it's
a way it's a normal way
that other people think is abnormal ryan
seacrest tom cruise oprah steven
spielberg
donald trump still pumping and working
as a billionaire
look if you're not working at that level
you're not going to make it get your
work ethic in man it's the american way
work ethic check it out my question was
actually about
it was about work ethic and
self-discipline
and so for somebody to to work as hard
as you do
as long as you do for as long as you
have been i mean
and you don't stop you know how can you
work to develop
a self-discipline that's just
untouchable the work ethic's a big thing
man
beat the sun up that's one thing you
know there's not a formula it's like
what do you have to do
uh to build a work ethic um beating the
sun up it's
it's it's just you'll never feel bad
cause you beat the sun up
i don't care you [ __ ] about it the
whole morning all the way up
until you finally wake up and then
you're gonna be like man i'm sure glad
this was awesome there's something
happens before suns come up that
is different the most different part of
the day it makes you feel good about
yourself at the end of the day
on victories like on victories
i see two so many people get sucked into
their own victories
and because their work ethic's broken
they don't keep working they're like oh
pat on the back
i got my deal let's go let's take a
vacation
and and you see the destruction of these
people
you know tom brady wins the super bowl
he he he he that night he's preparing
for the next one
the work ethic is just of all the top
people are so severe
so it should be something that's great
it's a great first question
it could be a whole book
because because one of the things and
and the last thing i'll say on this is
this helps me by the way just you asking
me this really the whole thing helps me
uh the work ethic thing is
it's also so that you start pushing
whoever that
whoever you're you're in a space with
and you're competing with
you know you you want to make you want
to do some flexing
and the flexing doesn't have to be the
car because you can't go back
you can't just keep buying cars you can
flex work ethic
there's no budget you can't go broke on
it it's never going to be bad for you
it might bother your spouse
kids it's not it's never going to bother
kids don't kid yourself get the kids
want you
just enough and then they're done
they're like okay get out of here so
that whole thing they played this thing
out in the 80s i think you know oh
kids the equality a quantity at the time
the kids just need a quality time
but they don't want three hours no kid
wants three hours to their dad
maybe your stuff mine doesn't am i right
on this i only have two kids so i don't
know
and in 17 18 years old they're not gonna
want any of my time
then they'll come back around later when
they want money
and i'll be like go get your own money
but uh
but the work ethic the the you know i do
a lot of flexing
on the on the work ethic thing to tell
people where i've been where i'm going
how much i'm going what i'm doing
it's not for for customers it's for my
staff
and it's for the competition or anybody
that thinks their competition
and we're convinced we're convinced i'm
the most
disliked speaker in the space
by our contemporaries uh jared and i
were talking about this the other day
there's guys there's there's just the
space is very small that i'm in so
and so we know everybody knows everybody
and
we i told you that i said the the the
deal is they don't understand how i
worked it like this
because they're not they're picking up
their two or three million bucks a year
and they're like man i'm posting on
instagram getting their likes probably
buying them
and and then they're like look at me
look at me and i'm not i'm not
that's not what i want and so they're
like why is he why does he keep driven
like this
driven is the like it's a huge asset if
you can find if you can tap into it
because most people cannot tap into it
and this comes right out of the book if
you're not first or last
if you can do what other people can't do
if you do what they refuse to do
if you become an asset where they have
liabilities
you will just it's a natural crush
and more work ethic's one of those
things hey hope you're doing well today
[Music]
really important message
about simplicity about what really
matters
don't let all the fancy cars
uh sparkles in the ceiling
logos on the seat backs
private aircraft
[Music]
orange lambos don't let all that
don't let all that fool you okay none of
that is who
any of us are those are just things you
buy
hopefully you acquired it all by doing
the right things
look i'm just a simple guy been working
my ass off for 30 years
showing up when i didn't want to doing
whatever it takes
figuring it out making little shifts and
changes
most of the time don't even know what
the hell i'm doing just want to let you
know man i i i
it's popular now with instagram and
youtube everybody's an expert
everybody knows everybody look i do
deals today
my first house i bought was 78 000 i'm
doing a deal right now for 86 million
bucks
you're doing the deal the whole time i'm
like man am i doing the right thing am i
you know so if you're right more often
than you're wrong
you win that's the simplicity of it you
can't be right more than you're wrong
if you don't swing if you don't play the
game
if you don't study if you don't tweak
you know if you're not willing to make
changes if you're not willing to make
new connections
hook up with new people get new
information it's work
it's work bottom line it's work fancy
cars the planes
uh the vacations it's not an instagram
post okay
it's not it's not seven or eight words
it's not 104 characters
it's freaking work it's everyday action
it's disappointments discouragements
obstacles
it's barriers if you're feeling down if
you're wondering why it's taking you so
long
you go online you go on facebook or
instagram you see some guy with a lambo
or
a ferrari or whatever the car you want
you know a rolls
and you're like man i want all that why
don't i have all that trust me
okay if he if he got it legitimate if he
got it legit
and if he or she is able to keep it
because not everybody's gonna keep all
that [ __ ] they're showing off you know
that's true
then um
they worked okay they work there's no
freaking like magic
act okay some online
phenomenon that's gonna like
that guy almost just jacked me okay it's
work man it's disappointment
discouragements it's barriers and
obstacles
the guy that wins the gal that wins is
the person that thinks big
thinks big and giant never quits refuse
to quit
does whatever it takes no matter what i
wish this could be more instructional
than it is
if you agree post a comment if you
disagree please post a comment i love
the disagreers okay if you hate
well look look we know you're not doing
anything okay i just don't get the
haters man the haters like
you hating on me when you hate on me you
don't do anything
you know it's not a product so hope
you're doing well hope you're following
this channel
we drop video here two and three
different videos a day
everything from real estate to finances
to sales to marketing promotion
to how to do a video while you're
driving a car that's crazy
so look hope you're doing well hope
you're doing great if you needed this
right now
post it in comments and if you like the
channel hey
give me a little like up like up you
know just got back from
houston we brought seven 27
145
individual supplies there and distribute
them to people in need
get yourself in a position where you can
help more people god bless be great help
yourself first
help yourself first get yourself right
and then you can help a whole bunch of
other people too okay
don't be fooled by fancy cars dude i'm
in the desert right now doing deals
okay i mean and literally look
what's the difference 141 million or 140
million dollars on 140 million dollar
deals i mean let's just do this thing
and get it done
i'm out here in the desert how hot is it
out here
in the moment sir i'll say about 100
let me just get my it's a cool winter
day it's a cool
106. it's 106 degrees out here dude look
look at you jacking me around about what
million dollars let's do the deal just
do the damn deal just say yes to me
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag billionairemindset in the
comments below
so i can celebrate you hard work is your
ticket in
no matter where you come from what you
look like what your skills are
hard work is always the ticket in
the odds might be against you awesome
now what
quit on your dreams or keep working hard
how you answer that question will change
your life
so i have an agent in new york and when
i first started the agency i almost
didn't get in
uh i didn't get in because i'm a weird
case for them
my agent now he looked at me back then
and this must have been
six or seven years ago by now and he
said evan i love your message the
problem is
you're not a very good communicator and
that hurt at the beginning because i had
already done some speaking gigs i'd
already been making videos for three or
four years
you know i've had hundreds if not a
thousand videos already under my belt
and here he is saying
that i suck at communicating and he said
the people that he typically works with
are people who are already in media who
have tons of experience who are great in
front of the camera
they need help refining their message he
said for you i love your message you've
got a great message you just suck at
being
communicated like wow
and so okay great well where do we go
from here and he said
i'm going to take a flyer on you i don't
normally do this
i'm going to take a flyer on you and see
where you go and
i didn't want to waste my opportunity i
didn't even know that you could get an
agent as a as a business person as an
entrepreneur as a speaker i mean i guess
i heard of speaking houses but
an agent i thought more entertainment or
sports not for business
so i didn't want to lose this
opportunity you know i didn't want to
regret not giving it my best
and so i said okay great tell me what i
need to do i'm the worst right now
awesome i don't have the skills that
everybody else here has
how can i get better what do i need to
do tell me and he said okay
so your first challenge is i need you to
make a bio video i need you to tell your
story a foundation story video
make it 20 to 40 minutes long and
record it and i'm going to look at it
and i'm gonna give you my feedback on it
okay great so i recorded it the next day
and it was in the morning i recorded it
sent it to him he gave me feedback
and then at lunch i recorded it again he
gave me feedback i recorded it again in
the evening
and i did it 30 to 40 times there's a
lot
over over the course of however many
days you know uh
10 to 12 days i guess uh i recorded the
video over and over and over and over
and over and over and over again every
time i give me feedback i do it again
feedback do it again
and i got better and i got better and
over the course of a couple months
when i was making three videos a day
practicing
sucking but just practicing and trying
to get better and listening feedback and
trying to improve
i quickly became the best case at the
agency i quickly became the number one
person
from from views from subscribers from
best practices i copy what evan's doing
now i'm being brought on to help them
with their clients and train some of
them on how they can get better
on youtube and build their brand from
being the worst from the guy who almost
didn't get in
because the people who were joining them
one maybe had bigger egos but also we're
having a hard time
finding the time to make a video a week
and if they're not making a video a week
or having a hard time doing it and i'm
making three a day
even if i suck i'm gonna get better i'm
gonna outpace just because i'm willing
to work
just because i'm putting in the effort
you might not have the skills you might
not have the talent
you might not have the looks you might
not have what you think you need to have
how does an introvert build a huge
audience and
spread a huge message and be famous on
youtube i don't know i mean i'm working
on it join me on my journey
we'll figure it out together that was my
agent's concern when i first got started
and i'm
i'm breaking the mold and doing things
in a way that haven't been done
and you can do the same thing through
hard work
hard work doesn't guarantee your success
there's a lot of people who work really
hard
and never win a lot of people who work
12-hour days
and are doing minimum wage jobs they're
working hard and they don't win
you have to work hard and you have to
work smart but it's not one or the other
the people who were in the agency were
working smart but
we're making one video a week i was
working less smart
but making three videos a day so i'm
gonna get better i'm gonna get smarter
i'm gonna make it faster i'm gonna i'm
gonna show you what i can do
hard work is always your ticket in and
one of the biggest problems is people
just aren't working either hard enough
or smart enough
you just want it too soon and you can be
impatient and it's amazing
but better than being impatient with the
results is being impatient with yourself
most people are impatient with the
results like it's not coming fast enough
like where are my subscribers or my
views it's not happening
my first video took me a year to get
three comments and the first one was my
mom and second
sister and the third was some random
dude right a year to get three comments
and two of the people were in my family
you're impatient with the results what
you should be is impatient with yourself
when you're not getting results when
it's not happening
audit yourself are you putting in the
work are you doing enough work are you
working smart enough are you
applying the right strategies get more
frustrated with yourself and your effort
more than that the results aren't there
because if you woke up every day and did
that equivalent of making three videos a
day
when other people are making one video a
week you will eventually win
it might be slower than you'd like but
it's always slower than you like
but you will eventually win because hard
work is always your ticket in
so what's the process i'm going to give
you three steps to follow that i think
will help
step number one is have a mission i'm
actually not a big believer in having
10-year goals
um i i think to know what you think
you're capable of in a 10-year window is
ridiculous
think about who you were 10 years ago
there's no way that person can predict
where you are right now
not if you're growing none of you're
having any kind of success not if you've
evolved as a human
the goals you had 10 years ago i'm i'm i
just started my youtube channel 10 years
ago
right 29 years old 10 years ago
i was just starting my youtube channel
there's no way i could predict where i
would be here the goals that i would set
for myself when i was 29
would be totally off compared to where
i'm at right now it's great i think you
can have a 10-year goal i think you can
hit it the problem is i think that's
small compared to what you're capable of
so instead you have a mission something
that motivates you something that drives
you something you want to work hard at
every day
something so big that you will never
accomplish in your lifetime and yet you
wake up every day you want to
take another spoon from the ocean right
every day you take another spoonful out
of the ocean you're never going to take
all the water out but you took another
spoonful
and another spoonful another spoonful so
what's your mission more important than
having a 10-year goal
what is the mission that you are on that
you have to see
birth into the world because it matters
because you're built to serve
because you want to have an impact on
the people around you number two is have
play bigger triggers i'm a big believer
in play bigger triggers which means you
have things in your environment
that trigger you for success so the
doritos bag here no i'm not sponsored by
doritos it's a play bigger trigger
i want to eat these all day long it's a
reminder to myself that i'm stronger
than the doritos because damn the
doritos
these pictures all mean something to me
they all mean something they may not
mean anything to you but they mean
something to me
the plots down there from my youtube
awards mean something the cast that you
can't really see but what i wore on my
neck for for 60 days when i broke my
neck in two spots on my first trip
my first tour this year it means
something to me my first camera is down
there too that i use
for two years all these things it
reminds me of who i am
it reminds me that i'm that i'm stronger
than i am
right now in the moment that i'm capable
of great things that i
i finished my tour with a broken neck in
two spots and still went to
another 30 days on the road that's crazy
right it's it's hard to imagine that i
did that
and so that's that's how i remind myself
that i did that i have the i have the
cast there and so whatever makes you
feel bold
whatever makes you feel confident
whatever makes you feel alive
put it in your environment your physical
environment your actual office where
you're doing the work
but also your virtual environment what's
on the background
of your cell phone what's on the
background of your desktop right what do
you have you're looking at it multiple
times a day
does it fill you up so having to play
bigger trigger for yourself
what do you need to have in your
environment because you only set it up
once
right i only set this up once i only put
this here once
and every day i walk in and it triggers
me for success every single day
and set number three is pass the pillow
test so i have a pillow test where if
you have a pillow
right before you hit the bed before you
hit your pillow your before you don't
hit the pillow before you hit your head
on the pillow
you're very angry you can hit the pillow
before you hit your hand on the pillow
ask yourself are you proud of the effort
that you put
in tonight that's the pillow test if you
woke up every day and you were proud of
the effort even if you didn't get the
results but you are proud of the
effort that you put in that today i did
something that made me feel proud that
was outside my comfort zone that i
wanted to quit but i kept going
regardless and i did another take
another video even though it didn't get
the result i'm proud of what i did today
if you woke up every day and did that
and you're proud of your effort
you're going to create amazing things
most people
aren't proud of their effort most people
will do just enough
just enough of what the client wants or
just enough of what you think your
your audience wants your customers want
or just just enough you do just enough
you have to do more than just enough tie
yourself worth to the effort you're
putting in instead of the results
ask yourself tonight are you proud of
the effort that you put in
i'm proud of the effort i'm putting it
on this video do i get a result do you
love it maybe yes maybe now maybe it's
the worst video of all time for you
that's on me i need to get better i'm
working on it every single day i'm
trying but i'm proud of
the effort that i put it i'm trying i'm
trying
and if you woke up every day and you
were trying your hardest chasing down
the goals and the life that you want
you're going to get it you're gonna get
it because you're unstoppable
but only if you're putting in your
maximum effort every day
and you pass the pillow test cold
calling still works
it's just not as effective anymore
advertising on cable tv
still works it's just not as effective
anymore
billboards still work just not as
effective anymore
success in any field will come down to
both working
smart and working hard you need both
lots of people work hard and never get
anywhere they never get results
they stay small but they're working hard
and lots of people work smart
but they never win because they're not
working hard enough it's the combination
you need
both so the message i take from dane
here is you need to work hard
that you need to you have a goal and you
attack it that if your goal is to call
200 people a day that you are off
attacking that goal that you're not
giving up that you're not letting
excuses get in the way
that you're not letting other people's
judgments or say hey take it easy
you want a different life than the
people around you and to do that you
need to work hard
and attack your goals daily so that's
working hard
but for the working smart part because
remember we need both for working smart
i just wouldn't put cold calling at the
top of the list of things to generate
sales and be effective
here are the three ways that i do it
that maybe you can learn from
number one is i create content i would
much rather create content that is a
magnet that brings people to me
than me having to go chase people down
when you create content like i do on
youtube here
the content you have can generate leads
and sales and awareness and attention
and distribution in partnerships
media exposure forever right i have
videos here on youtube
that 10 years ago when i started my
channel are still getting views
are still getting subscribers are still
generating attention are still
generating leads
for my business and so the more that you
can create content
around your theme your ideas your
message you're an expert you've got
ideas that are different
right you've got strategies that are
different you see the world in a
different way
share it with me tell me and people will
find it
and people will come to you and it's way
easier to convert somebody who's coming
to you
than for you to go off and cold call
them the second way i generate sales is
through relationships
so i spend a lot of time on
relationships and this
might be counterintuitive because i'm an
introvert and so
i'm not out networking i don't go to
networking events i'm never gonna got to
introduce myself and say hey i'm evan
what do you do
that is not me i don't talk to the
person on the elevator
or on the dog walk or on the airplane
next to me
not on the airplane next to me you can't
do that on the airplane seat next to me
i don't i don't do that i'm introverted
but i value relationships and the longer
you stay in something especially when
you start to show results and you get
good at something you acquire skills you
start to connect with people and then i
make it a point to try to bring them
value and so
i have a list of maybe about 50 people
now
that every quarter i try to bring some
kind of value to
people who have accomplished a lot more
than me a lot of people who i profile
on this channel even guys like dan pena
and garyvee
and and mel robbins and grant cardone
and tony robbins and all these people
that i profile that i
have built some connection with i try to
find ways to bring them value
at least once a quarter and so i have a
simple evernote file
and i have my key contacts in there and
so i make a point of looking at that
evernote file every week and if there's
somebody who i haven't brought
value to in the past three months then i
i find a way to bring value
i find a way maybe i give them a tip on
their youtube strategy
maybe i reshare something that they're
trying to get exposure for maybe i find
out that they're doing
a new book launch and i try to help out
as much as i can i try to find out
something that i know is important to
them and figured a way to add value and
and that takes some sleuthing
some people are a lot easier than others
but
doing the work building their
relationships because those lead to
connections those lead to business
growth those leads to things coming back
to you
so quick example with gary vee gary
launched his
new wine collection empathy wines and
he's been promoting on his youtube
channel
i'm not a big wine drinker i don't
really know people who are drinking a
bunch of wine my dad makes his own wine
um so i could be a customer i guess i
could buy
a bottle a week or whatever his program
is
but more important is can i be a
distribution for you
and so i messaged him and his team and
said hey when we do a lot of gary videos
do you want to have a custom message can
we put something at the end of it that
talks about empathy wines
and so he sat down with his team and he
filmed this video evan thank you so much
for having a couple seconds
and being able to tell the believe
nation a little bit about empathy wines
it means a lot to me that you would take
this valuable
real estate and and time on your channel
to give me some love
means a lot it's just good karma points
and it's in that it's the major karma
points for you
right that's what that's what i want for
you guys i want people to feel like
not that they owe you karma points but
that you're giving them so much value
that you that you're a name
that when you ask for something because
eventually you're going to need help
right nobody's an island that they want
to open that email that that
they will struggle to try to find a way
to help you because you've given them so
much value
and so make a list mine's about 50
people make however long a list you want
are people that you want to stay in
touch with you want to bring value to
you want to find ways to help them out
that you're following them on on social
media and you're seeing what they're
paying attention to and where they're
engaged
and what they're talking about and then
try to find a way to help them when they
need help
that gives you major comment points and
that's going to come back to really help
your business grow
building the relationships and then step
number three for me is
i speak so speaking at events speaking
at paid events where i travel
around the world or my own events where
i do my tours
now did the 2019 tour planning 2020 tour
90 days 23 cities east coast texas maybe
mexico
uh doing free events here in toronto
where i speak once a week when i'm in
the city
speaking speaking speaking speaking you
can record it that becomes content back
to point number one of make content
but speaking at events it gives you
authority it connects people to you
people want to come up and talk to you
afterwards that leads to a lot of
business opportunities
you're an expert you're a genius you
have ideas that people need to hear
and so look at different events that you
can either host yourself or you can get
on stage
where other people are hosting whether
you get paid or not
just to build the experience to build
the credibility and build the contacts
to be seen as the go-to person for xyz
in your industry so it's that
combination of working both hard and
smart
that's not one or the other successful
people do both there is no longer any
acceptable reason why you can't get the
mentors that you're after and start
winning
the opportunities out in front of you
right now did not exist
for your parents and it's only getting
easier but you still have to do your
part you still have to reach out you
still have to want it
it's actually less about winning the
lottery and where you came from
and much more about how badly do you
want it and how much you're gonna put in
to get after it because if you are
willing to put in the work
you can beat out somebody with a
thousand times more resources than you
so every night i go on twitch and i
stream my league of legends games
twitch.tv slash believe team here and
there was a guy who joined me
last night from the philippines he's
from the philippines and he says that
his goal is to be a professional league
of legends player
and the challenges is not a big league
of legends scene in the philippines
there's no professional teams
there's only one player right now named
smithy who's
a jungler where did he go he was jungler
for team liquid
and he signed with the new team it
escapes me right now there's one person
who was born in the philippines who was
a pro player right now and mix is living
as a professional league of legends
player
this guy joins my live stream last night
and he says he's a support player from
the philippines and that's his ambition
he's going to grind it out he wants to
get noticed he wants to get picked up he
wants to be a professional
league of legends player the crazy thing
is
that's actually possible it's actually
possible for him to do it it's actually
possible for him to get
training for him to get mentorship for
him to reach out to for him to get in
contact with people here he is he's in
philippines
i'm in canada and we're talking and
we're connecting on my live stream
it's actually possible it wasn't
possible even 10 years ago
definitely not for his parents you look
at what his parents are doing
where they came from you could have some
dream but at that time the gym was
probably
just to come to north america or just to
have this
one little thing that that existed in
the world currently right
this limited mindset because there were
limited opportunities
but right now the opportunities are
insane you have a thing called the
internet
people didn't have it before the
opportunities are insane you are
competing against the world
which is bad for a lot of north
americans
but it's amazing for everybody who's
outside or amazing for anybody
who's willing to work hard it's not even
bad for north americans it's bad for
anybody
who's lazy who's slow who's maybe had
things handed to them there's a lot of
people in north america who had nothing
handed them but they're willing to work
hard
if you are willing to work hard if you
are willing to show yourself it's never
been easier to win justin bieber got
discovered on youtube you don't need to
have a manager anymore
you don't have to go through the system
you don't want to i got a publisher for
my deal but
you don't want to have a publisher you
don't publishers reject you great go off
and self-publish
david goggins did lots of people created
number one bestsellers
just from self-publishing you can bet on
yourself if you're willing to work hard
if you're willing to put in the effort
it's never been easier to win and so i
look at this guy from the philippines
it might be easier for me right me
sitting here in canada
if my goal was to be a professional
league of legends player
sure it might be easier for me sure i
might have more resources sure i could
afford coaching and
go to tournaments and meet people but
it's also never been easier for him
because in the past it would have been
only available to me
now it's available to anybody and if he
has the heart and the hustle and the
drive and the intention and the will to
go off and do it every day
he can crush someone like me even if i
have a thousand times more resources
than him
and you can too how i'm gonna give you a
three-step process
so step one is find aspirational mentors
find people who
you want to be like maybe they're from
the same country as you maybe not maybe
the same background as you maybe not but
they
they're doing the thing or they have
done the thing that you want
and learn from them there's videos on
them there's books on them there's
podcasts on them there's
interviews with them learn from them
study them for two things one
just the the motivation to know that if
they could do it you could do it too
right just the the hope this is why i
started doing what i did
in terms of modeling success and having
these people you know behind me on my
wall and why i do all these youtube
videos
is because i wanted the hope the belief
that if other people could do it i could
do it too
i look at somebody who came with less
chances are the people who you look up
to started with less than what you
already have right now
and so seeing that they came from there
and accomplished this thing
makes me feel like i can too it gives me
hope and second it gives you strategies
you look at what they did and say wow
this is what they did this is the path
they took
i can copy that success leaves clues it
won't lead you to all the way a hundred
percent
but if it gets you eighty percent of the
way all you have to do is figure out
that last twenty percent
because they took you eighty percent of
the way and said you figured everything
out yourself i'm a product of learning
from jeff bezos
from steve jobs from kanye west from the
people that i profiled
on my channel i'm a product of
aspirational mentorship i may never meet
jeff bezos
i probably won't get the chance to work
under him
and be mentored by him and sign up for
his coaching program
right probably not but i can learn from
him i did in this video and i've done so
in many other of the videos that i've
done on him too
you can too who has done what you want
to do and then be
around it daily number two is in-person
mentors you're looking at people who you
can
actually meet one-on-one people who
might be in your city
people who might be coming to your city
when i was doing my tour
people would come and meet me because
they wanted to ask me some questions
look at who's coming to your city or
maybe you have to go and do a one two
three
eight hour drive people came from boston
and new york to
to come and see me and interview me here
in toronto because they wanted the
one-on-one access right
especially if you're from far away
people will give you more time
and so find out who has done what you're
trying to do jeff bezos may not be
taking a meeting with you but there's
other people who've accomplished a
smaller version
you're now talking about learning from
the richest man in the world the
you know one of the most successful
people in the world there's a lot of
people who've done what you want to do
on a slightly smaller scale who are way
more accessible
reach out say you're trying to do this
one thing you have one question for them
and that's the key
don't go to somebody and say will you be
my mentor don't do that
it's disrespecting their time just say
you have one question for them you have
one question
and then get the answer most mentees
suck most people will come back then
a week later and say oh i have another
question like don't worry what happened
to the first question
did you did you do it i told you to do
this what did you do like oh
that was too difficult or it didn't work
out not acceptable
not acceptable if you get advice from
somebody
for the one question it's the most
important question for you you have to
go off and do it
and if it doesn't work out if it works
out great then come back and ask another
question say hey i followed your advice
look at what i did
now now i'm facing this problem right if
it doesn't work out though
they might ask well how many times did
you try it and it better be at least a
hundred
if you said that you tried it two times
and it didn't work out you're totally
disrespecting their time don't be a
sucky mentee that's a brutal attitude to
have
if i told you make a video and give you
feedback on how to make a video
and then you went off and saw it didn't
work how many times did you try
three times i don't want to see you're
wasting my time
why you why are you disrespecting coming
with another question
when you haven't even taken the effort
on the first one that was so important
to you
right now if you said i did 100 videos
i recorded 100 videos and it still
doesn't work out
i badly want this to work then i'll take
a look i'll take a second look because
you're putting in the effort
the problem is the mentor is putting in
the effort you're not matching it
even though it might be only 15 minutes
of effort for them their time is a lot
more valuable than yours
right now right so their effort is not
being matched by your effort you need to
match you need to come up and you need
to put in massive effort and then they
want to help you again
so first is aspirational mentors second
is in-person mentors
and then the third would be online
mentors and these are people who you can
meet
even even right now you can meet me i'm
doing a twitch stream
probably tonight you can go twitch.tv
believe team come join me
i do instagram lives whoever you're
looking up to
chances are they have some kind of live
stream or somebody in the industry
has some kind of way to reach out maybe
it's an instagram dm maybe they're going
live on instagram maybe they're going
live on youtube maybe they're going live
on linkedin
maybe they have a way to ask them a
question on twitter right this hasn't
existed
typically right this is a new phenomenon
in the past 10 years where
people who you look up to respect admire
you can actually ask them a question
and get a response even though you may
never meet them
i think about when i was younger um i
love the toronto blue jays i love the
toronto blue jays
and i love baseball in general and so i
would write to the different
players on the blue jays as well as
teams to ask for an autographed card
and teams would sometimes write back and
i remember the first scene i wrote back
was actually the texas rangers gave me a
signed nolan ryan
uh picture nolan ryan hall of fame
baseball player one of the one of the
greatest pitchers of all time
and i sent a letter to them and talking
about why i love nolan ryan
and i don't know a couple months later
they sent me back in the mail i kind of
forgot about it but they sent me back in
the mail
this signed picture of nolan ryan and it
blew me away that
they actually took the time to read my
letter
now did nolan actually read the writer
probably not he probably has a stack of
cards that have just signed but
it made me feel special as a little kid
but that was think about that process i
had to write a letter and mail it and
then a couple months
later get a response now you can see
people on twitter and instagram
and youtube and you get freaked out when
they don't respond to you well
if you only write one comment don't
expect to get a response
right be a known quantity but the people
who have the knowledge that you are
after that can help you get to where you
need to be
are available they've never been more
accessible in human history
so how badly do you want it and are you
going to reach out or not
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there